hi there just a quick blood out those  lights just a quick one here for those  of you who live in canada i am going to  be on a television program tomorrow  saturday global television sixteen by  nine seven o'clock in the evening I  think across the country it's a program  about polyglots I was one of five  participants in a panel discussion in  Toronto I think they also interviewed  some other people but the whole show is  on this issue of polyglots to make  reference to babble no more the book  that I mentioned earlier I can remember  the name of the author anyway it's going  to be a program on global television all  about polyglots I'm one of the people  interviewed one of the participants if  you're interested seven o'clock saturday  evening Global Television just to let  you know and i'll put a link in the  comments or at least in the notes  section of the video here okay thank you  bye